foreign
comes from Cindy in Kansas she says we
have about 185 thousand dollars of
equity in our house with rates being
what they are right now is there
anything we can do with the with our
Equity or should we wait till rates drop
to possibly take out money to finish the
basement and redo the deck
we have great credit and owe 115 000 on
the house we just don't understand if
there is any benefit to having all this
Equity we do plan to move in the next
two years due to better schools with
pulling out would pulling from the
equity of our house to finish the
basement to increase our square footage
to 3 000 square feet be smart I got an
offer from the bank saying I could take
out an interest-only payment for 10
years but I never heard of that before
and I didn't know if it's a good thing
um
we're from the bank and we're here to
help yeah those words don't go together
and if they do their lies they're not
here to help
um I want to make sure we're speaking
the same language here because
words like debt and loans and interest
rates I don't care a whole lot about
that what I do care about is this equity
in your home and the great thing about
that Equity Cindy is that's of value to
you that's wealth that you're building
in your home and no I would not take
that out to do repairs you're stealing
and robbing from your future when you do
that what I would do is start putting
aside money to do those repairs on your
home yourself and pay cash for those and
you might be thinking yeah Jay but I'm
going to move in two years and you know
won't I get the money back
maybe maybe not but I'd rather have that
money in equity so that when I go to
move you're getting all that money back
to put on your next home if you take all
that money now you're not going to have
much of a down payment to roll over into
the next home does that make sense so no
I would not pull out all of that Equity
as a matter of fact depending on what
your situation is if you don't have any
debt I'd actually double down and start
paying more to pay off the home or like
you said you could put some of that
money aside to save for the renovations
I would not deal with the bank on this I
would not go into debt for this
um not doing it that's all I can say
so um Cindy for though for you and those
like you that say um I never heard of
that before an interest-only loan
payment for 10 years oh interest only
means you paid only in the interest
which means you paid nothing on the debt
which means this goes on forever
and ever amen not only 10 years forever
and ever amen it just keeps going and
going and going going going there's no
end to it none whatsoever just goes on
you're gonna be in debt forever and the
the big problem with that is that you
write checks every month for the
privilege of
going nowhere
just running like a rat in a wheel
that's what interest only is no traction
no progress and we know from having
studied wealthy people that one of the
primary things people do there's two
things that really cause people to get
their first one million to five million
dollars in net worth the two primary
things are they invest steadily in their
retirement plans and good growth stock
mutual funds like 401ks and Roth IRAs
and they pay off their home
not pay only the interest and stand at
forever and ever and ever and ever so
the product that the bank is offering
you here is to screw you
which is what banks do
and they're there to mess you over
that's their job and they're good at it
and there's to take interest from you
and keep you in debt perpetually so
people that do this type of loan are
what we call middle class
perpetually
there's nothing evil about being middle
class but when you do middle class
stupid things that cause you to stay
middle class when you have the ability
to be much higher in the socio-economic
straighta meaning you had millions of
dollars in net worth and you had a great
solid wonderful golden rocking chair at
your retirement instead of I hope the
government will take care of me
which is well known for its ability to
handle money this is a stupid plan okay
so no we don't do that
so the the deal is uh you know there's
here's some things that uh you know we
could just take a second and talk about
this it's a good idea because I I grew
up in a uh
slightly lower middle class family okay
and so I watched people do middle class
stuff okay here's what middle class by
the way there's poor people stuff that
they do too sure and then there's rich
people stuff that you do yes and it's
not that one's a person is better by
character than another by doing these
things these are just the financial
moves that cause you to stay in one of
these areas okay poor people would be
payday lender yes pawn shop
Title Loans
pay at the pay uh payday payday loan pay
at the car lot whatever it is Tote The
Note
um
uh rent to own your freaking washer and
dryer and pay you about 5x for it when
you do that uh these are Poor People's
Lottery lottery is going to make money
Lottery by the way almost all lottery
tickets 78 percent of lottery tickets
are sold in poor zip codes
yeah and Tennessee the lottery money's
used to send uh middle class and upper
class people's kids to school they pay
for your they give you three thousand
four thousand dollars for tuition so in
Tennessee poor people are sitting rich
in middle class people's kids to college
so isn't that a wonderful program I just
love it it's awesome and so this is what
so that's poor people stuff okay middle
class people stuff is car payments car
payment I'm gonna get rich on uh airline
miles with my credit card he locks he
locks I'm gonna I'm gonna take a second
mortgage out interest only and fix up my
basement and build a deck uh because I
deserve it I believe all the sofa
commercials the pretty people student
loans student loans middle class uh some
lower class but mainly middle class keep
your middle class for ever
um
whole life life insurance
good one yes uh leasing a car
yes very middle class very middle class
so rich people don't ask how much down
and how much a month
they ask how much
they avoid payments they pay for it or
they don't buy and that's what got them
to be rich and it's what keeps them rich
and so the rich get richer and the poor
get poorer yep because you keep doing
the same crap that causes it in both
cases
and so you keep doing rich people stuff
you get to be rich people I'm telling
you you make Thirty forty thousand fifty
thousand dollars a year in America today
and you do rich people stuff for the
next decade you will not be you will not
be poor anymore no you'll be all right
you just do the stuff they do you pay
cash for things you buy used cars uh you
don't lease stuff you don't Finance your
freaking vacations yes you stay out of
the timeshare office you run the whole
life agent out with a stick out of your
living room get out get
yeah
you know you do this is what you do
right you do you start doing this stuff
I mean and it's not a it's again it's
not a character thing yeah because it
was a character thing I would not have
anything absolutely because I mean I I'm
so dumb I had to become a millionaire
twice I lost it all the first time
because I did stupid butt stuff so it's
not it's not that but here's figure out
and you know there's even stuff that
people do by age group okay number one
mistake people do when they graduate
from college student loans no they
already have those oh they buy a new
cars
they got their big boy big girl jobs and
I have to get a big girl car payment to
go with my big girl job because I I'm
embarrassed to drive the college car
uh-huh
God help you what a one percent problem
is that you had a college car
these are things that most people never
even dream of having in one sentence and
you had that regardless of if it was a
hoopty but I had to go get a 35 000 car
because the one I had didn't have an
airbag oh you're killing me here yeah
yeah so this is ding ding ding ding
there's age group mistakes there's
social stratum mistakes and or behaviors
that cause you to be in that social
strata so if you want to level up
you change your behavior that's right
you change your habits you change your
views where there is no vision the
people perish
that's like die
the vision is key and that is I want to
level up I'm going to do stuff I've
never done before so I have things I
never had before I'm gonna pay a price
to win I'm not going to follow all the
freaking all my broke friends I got an
opinion about money go do what your
broke friends do and see if you don't
look like one of your broke friends
that's pretty dumb